what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible yes we are and
we're running a little bit late here
but i guess better late than never it's
just been a really really busy week i'm
buying office space we're getting off of
space i'm excited about that so in any
event so what we end up doing is picking
up with the the last video that we did
well not really the last one the last
one was like a spider-man invincible
crossover but the one before that so
omni man is basically back here with
debbie and it's kind of crazy because
you end up having like invincible and
adam eve who show up and they're like so
we kind of have some news and they're
like what's that and omniman's like so
we're going to go to telescria and just
kind of spend time together it's like
well when are you guys going and it's
like right now and they like immediately
take off right so like they're out of
the picture now this is cool because
from this point going forward it largely
just focuses on mark right just kind of
focus on his character his development
that kind of a thing and he actually
ends up coming around to the proper way
of thinking and i'll explain what that
means here in a minute what we initially
do is pick up with this guy who's
basically stolen a briefcase of money
running around with a gravity gun and
then as soon as mark catches up to him
he's kind of like oh like i did not
expect invincible and then you get like
this whole explanation right this whole
like just hilarious and amazing exchange
so you end up finding out this guy's
name is chris and he actually invented a
gravity gun and the whole reason for
this is because he is trying to get
enough money to get an engagement ring
for his girl
so obviously this guy has no intention
of using you know his technology and
whatnot to like just rob arbitrarily or
something like that he has the right
motivation he's just doing the wrong
thing to achieve his goal and mark's
kind of like okay cool look i get where
you're coming from man i get that you've
you're kind of in a weird spot i don't
know why you would turn to bank robbery
for the purpose of buying an engagement
ring right like why would you risk your
freedom
to buy a ring to marry your girl right i
mean like you can find other ways and so
mark ends up taking the money to
basically return it to the bank right
just kind of you know no must no fuss
call it a day and then in turn he tells
them like just sell your weapons legally
right like like take your stuff and sell
it to like scientists or somebody like
that people who will buy it and give you
the kind of money you need in order to
you know be able to to get this
engagement ring right so it's kind of a
cool little thing but from that point
you actually switch over to vegas and
dinosaurs is just tearing everything up
right now here's a crazy thing about
this dinosaurus was almost kind of
depicted as like a freedom fighter or
really more of like a like a
environmentalist right like an extreme
environmentalist to a degree right in
the sense that like his philosophy is
you know humanity is in a lot of ways
kind of a scourge on the planet but more
so than that his whole stance here as
interesting as it is he argues that like
las vegas is a problem right that las
vegas is just this giant you know
adult playground out in nevada somewhere
and that the the entire landmass that it
takes up right all the energy it uses
that if it was all just eliminated it
could be replaced with like solar panels
right enough solar panels to actually
power the country and he's like this
place doesn't need to be here and so
he's essentially trying to tear it all
down and ruin it all so that he can
basically replace it with things that
would essentially make the country
better right i mean which one makes the
country better gambling your your kids
uh college fund away hoping that you can
make millions of dollars on progressive
slots which you really kind of know
you're never going to do or
building solar panels clean energy
and so ultimately he ends up revealing
that he's got a bomb planted in that
location uh mark ends up getting the
bomb but then that's when dinosaurs is
like no no no it would take more than
one bomb to blow this place up it would
take 50. and he's like in reality you
don't have enough to to stop them all
and then like the entire area explodes
like literally las vegas gets turned to
glass right like it's such a massive
explosion it re-materializes the sand in
the desert and turns it all to a glass
surface now this is kind of view to a
degree as a catastrophic failure of mark
both in terms of how he sees himself and
to a degree in terms of how the world
sees him right i mean they know that
dinosaurs was the one behind this that
this guy was the one that caused this
great big huge calamity that everybody
who is in vegas for the most part a lot
of people have been evacuated not
everyone but the entirety of vegas has
been totally destroyed right totally
obliterated and so at that point you
learn a couple different things one
cecil is watching all of this unfold
right so you already kind of know how
things are going to go with him and two
dinosaurs survived the experience now
the funny thing about this is dinosaurus
refers to his human version as like his
frail form so in a lot of ways dinosaurs
is really kind of a kind of an allegory
for the incredible hulk or really just
kind of a pastiche of the incredible
hulk in the invincible series albeit
take away the idea of the incredible
hulk just being like a mindless brute
that wants to be left alone and just
smash his stuff and just kind of switch
him over to being this kind of you know
uh environmentalist guy who believes
that like a lot of the stuff that
humanity does it's really just making
things worse as opposed to making things
better right that's what a lot of that
turns into and so you do have a few
things that take place here most notably
one of the big issues mark is contending
with is the idea that while he and adam
eve have like invincible ink and they're
kind of like a small little superhero
team or superhero organization that they
have the power to make the world better
the reality is that things just keep
getting worse but the biggest problem
with this is that mark is looking at
everything from a short term perspective
right like the destruction of las vegas
i mean sure it sucks that vegas got
blown up the reality is some good could
actually come out of that and we'll see
how that takes place but that's one of
the biggest issues that mark has like so
many of us he's looking at the short
term in the moment this is bad therefore
it will always be bad which is not true
right like things may suck in the moment
but they can get better later on down
the line at the end of the day it really
all comes down to how much of a
sacrifice you're willing to make and
that's one of the things that we'll talk
about you know as we kind of get further
through this but what you actually end
up doing is switching over to the return
of robot and monster girl right now
these characters had at one point in
time been basically sucked into the
portal to the thraxion realm and just
kind of been ruling it for about 12
years and so robot showing back up here
while it was 12 years there it was
nowhere near as long here it was like
eight months right it was basically the
time that invincible was gone when he
was out in space during the viltrumite
war and so one of the things that
happens is one robot wants to be
referred to as rex that's the name he
wants to be called seemingly it's kind
of a bit of a way to honor uh rex float
the other part of this is that because
he was the leader of the guardians of
the globe for a time that in turn
because cecil has what is basically an
expanded superhero roster so you've got
capes incorporated you got the
actioneers you have wolfman and the
wolfcore you got tech jacket of course
we're already familiar with him from the
vulture my war uh you have basically
these big superheroes of teams
especially when it comes to the expanded
roster of the guardians of the globe
something that i also want to point out
here i believe these all have individual
comics so if you're interested we can
cover some of them i can't promise that
all of them are interesting but we can
cover some of them but he basically says
like because you have and historically
have been the best person suited to
basically run a superhero team
specifically the reformed guardians of
the globe i want you to run all these
teams right i want you to basically be
the leader of all this stuff and
ultimately robot is not how he used to
be if you guys recall when he was in his
younger human form and even before that
when he was really just a robot while he
was you know a machine there was a
little pep in him right a little kind of
like yeah you know these are kind of
cool he doesn't really have that anymore
right like that's basically gone for the
most part he's just really struggling
with depression is what it looks like
and maybe even a little ptsd thrown in
there but he's really just kind of a
shade of his former self in a lot of
different ways but ultimately he ends up
taking it under the idea that it's a
welcome distraction from whatever it is
that he's dealing with at the moment
that's what you end up doing is
switching over to monster girl who in
the 12 years that she's been out there
she's kind of grown up to a degree and
things are a bit on the rocks right i
mean something seems to have happened
during their time when they were
basically ruling the flaxon empire that
things have just kind of been
irrevocable in some form or fashion we
don't really know how we don't really
know what it is that took place we
simply just know there's a rift between
them now that simply wasn't there before
now as far as mark goes this is one of
the ways in which mark's thinking is
basically beginning to turn around that
he has this conversation with cecil
where he says like he imagines a time
when he doesn't really have to wear a
costume anymore right when he can just
kind of do his thing just sort of live
his life and the world can basically
take care of itself it is a lot of
pressure on mark with regards to the
fact that he is the strongest superhero
on earth a lot of the other heroes don't
really seem to measure up to the various
challenges that are out there so whether
cecil would admit it or not it usually
ends up coming down to mark but one of
the things that he starts to realize is
that a lot of what cecil has done in so
far is locking up different heroes
keeping them contained confined that it
really was the right thing to do given
the circumstance he's coming more around
to the thought process of cecil that
he's not really a straight villainous
guy and even this kind of ties into the
idea that mark's history of just like
punching the bad guys right and like
saving a bridge or something like that
that it doesn't actually fix anything
right like mark's actions up to this
point have basically been tantamount to
like protesting right like a person has
done something that i don't like so i'm
going to stand over there with a sign
for a day and a half and then go home
right like what like that's not gonna do
anything right like you're easily
ignored and you usually will be
you know protesting very rarely ever
solves anything so because of that it's
kind of mark's equivalent of that right
like i saved a bridge or a woman was
falling and i rescued her right like
this is cool in the moment but it has no
real lasting impact on anything and
doesn't really make the world better in
any real measurable way and so coming
around to to cecil's thought process and
basically realizing that in order to do
some good sometimes you got to do some
bad right like you got to be
machiavellian right you got to be
willing to be a terrible person if it
means the end result is a net positive
you have to lose yourself essentially
that sometimes that's just the way it
goes and so ultimately cece reveals like
hey okay look i'm glad you're thinking
this way there's some things that i've
been keeping from you and he basically
reveals to mark the fact that all those
different versions of invincible from
across the multiverse if you guys
remember that story with angstrom levy
where he had summoned those different
versions of invincible who were like
criminals and they were evil stuff like
that that a lot of those versions of
mark that were killed had been turned
into rihanna men right those uh those
kind of robotic zombified individuals
who basically just follow orders and
mark kind of looks around and where
cecil's expecting him to just freak and
lose his mind mark's like i mean it
makes me kind of uncomfortable but at
the same time it kind of makes sense i
could definitely see why you're doing
this right i mean the various forces
that you had before couldn't even stand
against me what hope would they have
against somebody who's slightly weaker
than me right like in order to do your
job effectively you're gonna have to
have forces at your disposal that can
basically go toe-to-toe against some
pretty heavy hitters and so mark's like
it doesn't change anything right if you
need me call me if there's nothing else
you need then i gotta bounce and he
basically leaves right he's perfectly
content with what it was that cecil was
doing whereas cecil was expecting this
just like huge just kind of popping off
right this sort of just explosion of him
basically losing his mind and so at this
point you switch back over to monster
girl and it's kind of funny because you
end up having this this scenario
where everybody is essentially macking
on monster girl and so while all this is
going on
all these guys are giving her this
attention that robot is just kind of
watching it go down right robots just
kind of watching it happen and it makes
him a little uncomfortable to a degree
and even kind of says that and in fact
there's one point during this party
where basically bulletproof is like hey
what's going on monster girl like i am
the king of getting people reacquainted
let's let's come hang out right we'll
get you reacquainted right now it's
turning into the opening scene of a
black episode right like that's
literally what it's turning into uh
don't ask me how i know that don't judge
me so nonetheless right it's like
ultimately she kind of nips that in the
bud right off the bat and it's like oh
no no no first of all nothing's gonna
happen right like we're not gonna be
knocking boots right that ain't
happening bulletproof she's like it's
just too soon right so seemingly the the
kind of blossoming romance right that
almost puppy love that existed between
monster girl and robot or i guess rex we
can call them now seem to kind of come
to fruition when they were in the when
they were ruling the flax and empire and
then fell apart but you get this kind of
crazy revelation here right where
they're basically in the kind of like
their base of operations that uh that
robot's getting ready to leave when
monster girl walks in you know and she's
like well i don't know you were here
like no it's fine i'm getting ready to
go and when he kind of asks you know
like it's weird being back after all
this time she wants to kind of talk
right you know she asked him like can we
talk he's like no she's like can we
please talk about it and he says i came
back here to leave behind everything we
built and forget what you did please
amanda why won't you let me forget so
seemingly whatever happened here was at
least it seemed to be a betrayal on
behalf of monster girl right that
monster girls seem to have done
something it's kind of wild but from
there you actually switch over to las
vegas now this is one of those instances
where i basically you know i presented
you guys this argument in order to make
an omelette you got to break a few eggs
does it suck that las vegas got
destroyed sure does it suck that a few
people died yeah but the end result is a
net gain and that's one of the big
issues one of the big things we've
talked about from a philosophical level
here on this youtube channel that there
are there's a lot of progress that
humanity can make but people allow the
this inherent value of a human life as
if there is such a thing to get in the
way of that right like everyone's life
is valuable every you know that should
never be sacrificed or compromised in
any way and in believing that humanity
actually ends up holding itself back
right preventing itself from becoming
something better and so because of this
this presents a scenario where in in the
place of of las vegas being totally
obliterated just by its sheer location
the entire area being turned to glass
that chris had actually been brought in
to work for cecil steadman and because
chris was basically a genius after
inventing that gravity gun that with his
intelligence and capabilities he
developed double-sided solar panels so
the solar panels can absorb energy from
the sun but because the sun of course
doesn't shine directly on the panels it
shines on the ground it hits the glass
and bounces back up to the other side of
the solar panel so basically they're
producing twice the amount of solar
energy that a normal solar panel would
be able to produce that this is a net
gain for humanity and all it required
was the sacrifice of some human lives
and at the end of the day if that really
is what happens then it is a better
thing right i mean you can't make an
omelet without breaking a few eggs i i
understand that people cherish the value
of human life i don't know why people
argue that human lives are just
inherently valuable right you are
valuable because you just exist and
that's enough right i mean if that's the
argument every fascist dictator in the
history of the world matters simply
because they exist right like we as
society create standards i would argue
arbitrary standards based on what
defines the value of a human life this
is a positive gain and it's one of the
things that said like this was
phenomenal and even mark is just like
damn man dinosaurus was right like las
vegas gets totally obliterated the place
gets turned to glass but the benefit the
net gain for society is inherently
better right a better thing came out of
the destruction of las vegas it just
took the destruction of las vegas and
the loss of a few human lives and that
was basically it and so again it's kind
of an interesting thing a lot of people
would stand against that and say no
that's never okay and to those people i
would say then you're the reason why
society doesn't progress but nonetheless
one of the things that actually goes on
here is mark sits down with uh with adam
e right after having this revelation
about dinosaurs he sits down with adam
eve and he's like okay so i need to ask
you something and she's like what he's
like you love me right you would always
love me like you would love me no matter
what and she says yes and he's like even
if i told you that what i'm about to do
or something that i am going to do flies
in the face of everything that we
believe flies in the face of everything
that we stand for and she's like okay i
mean the short answer is sure i mean you
know as long as it's not like some kind
of a heinous thing you're not gonna like
go the route of your dad and like just
you know try to conquer the world then
sure and he's very very cloak and dagger
about it doesn't really give her any
definitive answers but instead what we
end up finding out is that he agrees
with dinosaurs right that in order to
make the world a better place that
sometimes you got to sacrifice a few
things now the lengths at which
dinosaurs went to achieve his goal is
still a little extreme for mark and i
think for most people it would still be
a little extreme we'll eventually get to
that point when it's considered to be
acceptable but at the moment it's a
little extreme and so that's when mark
goes to visit dinosaurs with the
intention of breaking him out now this
is a big no-no man like dinosaurs
literally destroyed vegas so at this
point cecil's like no right we can't
abide this like this cannot be tolerated
but the funny thing about it is that
unlike the incredible hulk who
transforms through rage this guy only
turns into dinosaurs when he feels
indifferent right when he doesn't care
about what's going on at the time and
that's why he's surrounded by stuff
right he's in like a super comfy chair
he's watching like tv shows looks like
he's eating ramen right it's all based
on him just like caring about stuff
right being unable to be indifferent to
his situation and so he's like if you
want me to transform and for me to turn
into dinosaurs you got to make me feel
indifferent and so mark starts telling
his life story
the most boring thing there ever was
mark starts telling this story and then
like dinosaurs just like oh my god i
don't care boom he transforms right
turns into dinosaurs
and he's like okay so dinosaurs
obviously being the brains of the
operation it's almost like the
incredible hulk having the intelligence
of banner so like professor hulk
basically he's just kind of like okay so
if i deduce this correctly then you're
only here for a couple reasons you would
not break me out and you certainly
wouldn't have my other half transform
into me unless you absolutely have to
he's like so as unbelievable as it might
sound you seem to have come around to my
way of thinking that if you are really
wanting to help the world improve and
become a better place then you recognize
some folks are just going to have to die
but that's crazy right and mark's kind
of like okay look like i get what you're
saying right he says i have to admit
your methods are inexcusable to the
point that it's hard to just stand here
and talk to you you've killed so many
people destroyed homes an entire city
and he says all worthy sacrifices for
the greater good as i recall when your
father attempted to take over this
planet you fought him and in the process
some lives were lost what i did was no
different and ultimately mark says it
wasn't remotely no this isn't the time
for this he says what i'm getting at is
i've been dealing with this right being
invincible for a while now and i have
all these powers and i do what i do to
use them to help people i look back
after all this time and i think i don't
know that i'm actually helping anybody
right making the world better and i feel
like that's what i should be doing i'm
maintaining the status quo at best
simply just putting out fires and that's
one of the things that we've kind of
argued when it comes to superheroes
that's largely what they do right
superheroes are like the government
right like you know violence by a
different means right suppressing a
protest or a violent protest violence by
a different means right and so
ultimately superheroes exist to maintain
the status quo superheroes exist to
ensure that things stay the way they're
supposed to be if you look at
superheroes across the board that's the
case when has superman created a
circumstance whereby some popper down on
his luck has somehow managed to become a
billionaire right i mean i guess maybe
sending him to some shelter somewhere
but the help they get is designed to
help them stay where they are not become
better than what they are i guess maybe
on some kind of a moral and
philosophical level but not by tangibly
improving their lives that's the role
that superheroes play and that's the
role that mark plays right marcus is
kind of like i'm looking around and i'm
maintaining the status quo more so than
that dinosaurs is a hundred percent
right when a fight broke out between
mark and his father mark's biggest
concern was my dad has to be stopped
otherwise he's going to conquer the
world if he conquers the world then who
knows how many more other people will
die therefore anybody who does die and
any stuff that is destroyed in my fight
with my father well that's just an
acceptable instance of collateral damage
he didn't vocally say that but his
actions reflected that but one of the
funny things about this is that us as
like comic book readers or as human
beings we would arbitrarily create a
difference there using whatever desire
we choose to create that difference you
know we would just arbitrarily create
differences when in reality there isn't
one right it's just the difference we
create to maintain our own moral compass
and to basically prevent ourselves from
moving into the realm of accepting the
fact that in order for things to improve
usually some folks have to die and so it
gets kind of crazy because in the middle
of all this cecil just starts sending in
the reaniman right these invincible
reanimen
[Laughter]
sends these guys flying in there and in
turn like while they're literally
fighting him and trying to survive
against these just armies of armies of
marx then ultimately he's like okay look
you know i'm totally down with your
philosophy i like your idea you have the
ability to tangibly help the world what
i cannot do is stand by and watch as
innocent people die there has to be a
better way to do this the reality is
there are some but sacrifices are going
to have to be made right people are
going to have to be sacrificed for the
benefit of the greater good right the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few and so ultimately they kind of
agree and then dinosaurs like okay cool
i'm down with that get us out of here
and mark basically just just breaks him
out right at that point cecil goes to
adam eve and he's like yeah so like
basically mark broke dinosaurs out of
prison she's like what
no way right that's ridiculous but
ultimately you pick back up in the
secret base of dinosaurs and mark's like
let's save the world right like when
dinosaurs ask them are you ready to get
started mark's like yeah let's save the
world let's make the world a better
place with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace